The one thing about you
is you always seem positive.
I try to.
And that comes
through in the show.
And matter of fact, why
don't we take a look
at some of these
big moments for you
and how you came across as
always positive and happy.
[laughter]
Well, look at this.
This was the first big snow.
And this is when I
walked out of my shelter
in the first big snow.
And I started making
snow balls and juggling
because I was just so happy.
I felt good.
I was freezing my butt off.
And I was like, I got to go out
there and make some snowballs.
[humming]
What I'm going to
do, I'm going to make
a really cool Christmas--
I'm going to make Christmas
ornaments for our tree.
Damn.
That is going to
occupy a lot of time.
That's for Campbell.
I miss my family.
But I know they're
there waiting for me.
It's going to be all good.
So I'm all good.
That stone right
there that I just
kept writing family
in a piece of ash
over and over on the
stone is my motivation.
And that ended up being
the tattoo that I got.
Before I left, I found a
Mongolian tattoo artist,
and I got old Mongolian
script pronounced
[non-english speech].
And it says family.
HOST: Pretty good way
to remember the trip.
Thank you.